[Music]
for
Christian
[Music]
for
Christian
[Music]
I'll follow
you no nope I'm not making any
comments
hello
everyone
hello I don't can you hear me there we
go hello everyone welcome welcome to the
table it's good to see everyone here
welcome everyone online as well happy
Easter we'd like to welcome all of you
the kids here who are with us for the
service and today Pastor Brett promises
that he's going to keep that message
short and sweet so don't forget that we
have an Easter egg hunt today it's going
to occur immediately after the service
and so parents you can uh head with your
kids to the kids check-in table as soon
as we're finished um with the service
here okay also uh we're having that
Easter potluck tonight immediately
following the service it's in the Family
Life Center building which is
immediately behind this one even if
you're visiting with us and didn't bring
any food uh please come because there's
plenty for us to share with everyone
everyone all are welcome here so now let
us prepare our hearts and our soul gos
from
worship kind of let
everyone come on in
here yeah everyone come
on it is so good to see
everyone all
right let's just breathe in God's
love let's just just release out all the
burdens and the tensions
[Music]
and and let's know that God is
Holy
would you guys stand with us as we
worship
[Music]
tonight and all the Poor and
Powerless and all the lost and
lonely
all the lost and
[Music]
lonely and know that you are
holy and know that you are
holy and all will sing out
[Music]
High we will cry out
Hallelujah all the
hearts and all the hearts who are
content and all who feel
unworthy
and all who H with nothing
left know that you are
holy and all will sing
outu and we will cry out
hallelu and all will sing sing out
hu and we will cry out
[Music]
hallelu and
Shout go on and scream it from the
mountain
Mountains go on and tell it to the
masses he
is
God and
Shout
It Go on and scream it from the
mountain go on and tell it to the
masses
he
[Music]
God and
Shout
It Go on and scream it from the
mountain cry out go on and tell it to
the
m
you he
[Music]
is
shout
it go on and scream it from the
mountain go on and tell it to the
[Music]
mountain
he
God and we
will
on from
the out go on and tell
you sing
out is
God
shout
it go on and scream it from the
mountain go on and to the
m that he
is
God
Shout
go on and scream it from the
[Music]
mountain go on and tell it to the
master he is
[Music]
God this is a poem by Walter
bugman on our own we conclude that there
is not enough to go
around we are going to run
short of money of Love of
grades of publications of sex of beer of
members of years of life we should Seize
the Day seize the goods seese our
neighbors Goods because there's not
enough to go around
and then in the midst of our perceived
deficit you come you come giving bread
in the wilderness you come giving
children at the 11th Hour you come
giving homes to the Exiles you come
giving Futures to the
shutdown you come giving Easter Joy to
the
dead you come fleshed in Jesus
and we watch while the blind receive
their sight the lame walk the lepers are
cleansed the deaf here the dead are
raised the poor dance and sing we watch
and we take food we did not
grow and life we did not invent and
future that is gift and gift and gift
and gift and families and neighbors who
sustain us when we do not deserve it it
Dawns on us late rather than soon that
you give food in due season you open
your
hand you satisfy the desire of every
living thing by your giving break our
cycles of imagined
scarcity override our our presumed
deficits quiet our anxieties of lack
transform our perceptual field to see
the
abundance mercy upon
Mercy blessing upon
blessing sink your generosity deep into
our lives that your muchness May expose
our false lack that endlessly receiving
we may endlessly give so that the world
may be made Easter
new without greedy lack but only
Wonder without coercive need but only
love without destructive greed but only
praise without aggression and
evasiveness all things Easter new all
around us toward us and by us all things
Easter
new finish your
Creation in
Wonder Love and
praise
[Music]
amen
you are
not what you have
done or what has
been done to
you you are
something like the Rising Sun can't you
see that you are
new you might
have your father's
name or bear the
shame he left behind
but there's new life
flowing through your veins leave some
room to be
surprised you are
new every
morning you are
new Every Morning each day of
Resurrection it's waiting to break
[Music]
through you could
try just for a
start to put the
judge back on the
Shelf
all the
Ling
kindness in your heart have a
little for
yourself you are
new every
morning you are
new Every Morning each day your
Resurrection waiting to break
through you think hope is lost but it's
just
underground the flame might be an ember
but the Fire won't go
out all the evidence is pointing to the
truth that daily Resurrection is still
happening in you you are you are
[Music]
new every
morning you are
new Every Morning each day your
Resurrection is waiting to break through
[Music]
you are
new you are
[Music]
new like to read an account of the
resurrection of Jesus Christ from the
Gospel of John chapter 20
now Mary stood outside the tomb
crying as she wept she bent over to look
into the tomb and saw two angels in
white seated where jesus' body had been
one at the head and one at the foot they
asked Heroman why are you
crying they have taken my Lord
away and I don't know where they have
put him at this she turned around and
saw Jesus standing there but she did not
realize that it was
Jesus he asked Heroman why are you
crying who is it you are looking
for thinking he was the gardener she
said sir if you have carried him away
tell me where you have put him and I
will get
him Jesus said to her
Mary
she turned toward him and cried out in
Aramaic Rabani which means
teacher Jesus saido not hold on to me
for I have not yet ascended to the
father go instead to my brothers and
tell them I am ascending to the my
father and your father to my God and
your
God Mary Magdalene went to the disciples
with the news
I have seen the
Lord and she told them that he had said
these things to
[Music]
her
the moon in Stars they WEP the morning
sun was dead the savior of the world was
falling his body on the
cross his blood poured out for us the
weight of Every curse
upon
[Music]
him one final breath he gave his Heaven
worked
away the Son of God was laid in
Darkness a battle in the
grave the war on death was
waged the power of Hell
forever
broke the ground began to shake the
storm was rolled away his perfect love
could not be old
now death where is
your our
resurrected has rendered you
defeated
forever he is
glorified
forever he his
lifted High
forever he is
RIS he is
alive he is
a
forever he
[Music]
[Applause]
is
oh
[Music]
We Sing
Hallelujah we sing
hallelu We Sing
Hallelujah the lamb is
overcome we sing
Hallelujah We Sing Hallelujah
We Sing
Hallelujah the lamb is
over we sing
Hallelujah We Sing
Hallelujah we sing
hallelu the lamb is
overcome we sing
Hallelujah We Sing
Hallelujah we sing
Hallelujah
forever he his
glori
forever he is
lifted High
risen he is
a he is
alive
cuz death could not hold you the veil
torn before you you silence the boast of
sin and
Grave the heavens are
roaring the praise of your
glory for you are raised to
life
again cuz you have no
rival you have
noal now and
forever God you
Reign cuz yours is the
kingom yours is the glory
yours is the name above all
name what a powerful name it is what a
powerful name it
is the name of
Jesus Christ my
king what a powerful name it
is nothing can stand
against what a powerful name it is
the name of
Jesus what a powerful name it is the
name of
name oh
[Music]
Jesus
sing shout it and
Shout go on and scream it from the
mountains go on and tell it to the
masses
here
God
and
Shout go on and scream it from the
mountain go on and tell it to the
m he is
God and we will sing out how
[Music]
is cry out
how sing out
[Music]
how
shout go on and S it from the
mountain go on and it to the
[Music]
m
he God we
remember tonight
together that your love will
[Music]
SS over our sin over our shame over our
pain it is your love that has come to
make a
way it is you who calls us to be made
new to be
transformed it is you who has forgiven
us who has redeemed
us who has called us to be the best
versions of
ourself children of
God
beloved
whole God would you continue to make us
new and would we celebrate that life in
you together
tonight in jesus' name we ask all these
things and thank you for this time
together as we
[Music]
and I want to extend a warm welcome to
everyone um but as always that includes
those joining us online and uh anyone
here tonight who is new um maybe it's
your first time or just your first time
in a long time we're really really glad
that you're here I know it can be just
quite a nerve-wracking experience coming
to those doors and you're just like I
mean you're like you know like yeah know
they're nice I'm sure they're nice you
know but it's just it can be it can be a
lot so um so thank you just we want you
to know that you are very wanted and
welcome um in this space so the title of
my uh my message this Easter is awaking
to
Resurrection awaking to Resurrection and
our passage today is from 1 Corinthians
chapter 15: 42 through 45 where the
Apostle Paul wrote these words he said
so will it be with the resurrection of
the Dead the body that is
sown
perishable it is raised imperishable
it's sown in dishonor it's raised in
glory it's sown in
weakness you ever been there at the
moment when someone's passing from this
life to the next you know the the
weakness the frailty the just the the
fragility of that moment I mean it's
like it's difficult to be there and not
just feel like this is a holy moment
this is a holy m i see why um Humanity
has been kind of religious or spiritual
since I mean as far back as we have kind
of you know anthropology and the study
of early cultures because there just
there's certain things certain moments
that are just
sacred so he says it's it's there it's
sown in this weakness and this fragility
but it's raised in what and power it's
sown a natural body it's raised a
spiritual
body and then Paul the teacher kind of
comes out he says if there is a natural
body well then there's also a spiritual
body so it is written the first man Adam
he became a living being and then he
draws a connection and he says the last
Adam right that is Christ a lifegiving
spirit so the the question driving um my
my message this Easter is is really the
question of like how do we sink more
deeply
into these
truths like like in essence um I could
use the word believe but you'll see
throughout my message I really I'm not
so much talking like uh belief as in
this very kind of he thing like how how
do we believe you know I'm I'm thinking
more like like how do we believe in the
big sense like in the rich sense in the
sense where we we feel something like
down to our toes we just we just know we
just trust like there is something true
here something is resonating with me in
this moment it's like uh when you
experience like a poem or a work of art
and it just speaks to you even during
the like music and worship right you can
kind of feel something that's just
beyond like oh well they're technically
pretty good you know there's something
there's something more more that's
that's calling out to us so the question
is like how do we come to to sense that
to um to sink ever more deeply into it
to believe it to to trust it and then
kind of live from this truth right this
this truth that even though this
physical body that each of us has it
will one day be laid in the ground as PA
names it perishable Dishonored um kind
of weak frail natural but it doesn't in
there but one day I we all creation like
Christ will be raised how
imperishable glorified powerful
spiritual so so that's the question is
like how do we come to to like really
know
that so here's kind of my my big idea
for today I want to say that trusting
this kind of Resurrection Life it's much
less a kind of abstract idea or doctrine
or Dogma to be given mental Ascent to
and it's much more a spiritual reality
to be entered
into like in other words um there was a
season in my own uh kind of Christian
life where I really thought if only I
could get everyone to read academic
Christian
theology well then we'd be cooking with
Greece as my grandmother said you know
like you know what I mean like it was
this kind of hey intellectual thing but
I and I think that kind of has its um
its place so to speak um but I I think
there's there's something else kind of
going on something you might say that
comes kind of before that a sort of um
intuition a kind of inner
knowing and and this is how it was
thought of by like in the earliest
Decades of the Christian faith um the
idea was in essence you didn't just
believe intellectually right just
believe in God believe in Christ believe
in Resurrection Life and our problem is
we don't believe so we need to believe
more you know it wasn't so much just
about that the idea rather was um
something like Psalm 34 taste and
see that the Lord is good taste and see
right now that's that's that's something
slightly different right in other words
Christ God Resurrection all these things
we're we're singing about and declaring
like these are are less again kind of
intellectual things to like just come on
make make yourself believe you know it's
it's not so much that um these are
spiritual realities to be tasted seen
heard so to speak now I say so to speak
because I do not mean literally like
eaten with your mouth you know like it's
not not in that that sense of course I'm
thinking more of uh what ancient
Christians like origin um Gregory of
Nissa it's what they called the
spiritual senses they believe that in in
the same way we have like these five you
know physical senses um that we also
have another sense um or some believ
plural
senses this kind of
capacity to discern the spirit to to
sense to feel to know God in really deep
profound ways I think of a good analogy
it's sort of like I said earlier about
like when a a poem or a work of art
resonates with you and it like
something's sort of it's like speaking
to you in this really deep way and no
one could convince you otherwise you
know or I think of that that weird um
this is again a met metaphor so not
don't take this little literally but
like you know when you're lost and you
just have this like Knack this like
sense of where to go some of you have a
better sense of this and others mine's
not very good uh but you know where
you're just like I don't know how I know
but we're supposed to go left and then
lo and behold just like you know um it's
it's almost something like that where
again you can't necessarily rationally
explain like oh it's X reasons XYZ and
you know it's just not that kind of it's
like this deep inner kind of knowing and
this is what they would have called a
spiritual sense and so the idea would go
if um if we want to sink more deeply
into these truths right maybe you're
you're here today and you're kind of
maybe even struggling to believe like I
don't know Easter and resurrection and
the body and like how do I know you know
the the answer isn't um so much like
well read you need to read some you need
to read some Christian books you need to
read and then you'll be convinced you
know I I don't know I mean that can help
there is something to knowledge
understanding but I think there's
there's something that comes kind of
before that
some Whisper of the spirit some deep
calling out to deep within us and so the
answer um is is not so much like
academic or something it's the the
answer to how do I sink more deeply into
this truth of Resurrection Life how do I
know it deep within myself um that the
answer there is to have our spiritual
senses begin to come alive
again begin to
flourish again
now you might ask
uh how does that
happen and I think the answer to that is
is through very
intentional um embodied right so this
isn't about sort of sewing off into the
heavens become a person of the spirit
and you're just like ah I don't even see
the world you know that's not what I'm
talking about I'm I'm talking about a
very um kind of discipline kind of uh an
embodied uh practice like becoming a
person of Prayer of Silence of kind of
in aun in a tuned person you might have
met someone and you feel like they have
quite a
presence about them like what is what is
that how is that
developed that's some of what I'm
getting at it's that's like a kind of an
after effect of attuning yourself to God
right there's something that's kind of
developed in us so in other words if
you're here today and you're thinking
like I don't you know either a I don't
even know if I believe or B I believe
but like a little or I believe most days
but I have my doubts or I really believe
but like I want to sink even more deeply
into this truth I like I want to keep
moving I want to keep living
Resurrection Life well then my response
to that would not be again here read n
wrs gigantic book on the resurrection um
no my my answer would be great come and
engage
The rhythms and practices of Faith come
give yourself over to a life of prayer
and and searching like cultivating that
hunger that thirst for God like there's
there's just no other way now this is
the trick is we often like we want the
end at the beginning though right it's
sort of like well I would do that if I
had all the guarantees you know what I
mean it's it's almost we want the
results of this before we sort of commit
to the path but that is uh I would say
that's the trick of a life with God
there there is some there is this
invitation to kind of trust The Whisper
of God in the soul the whisper of Christ
in the soul and to say like okay okay
I'm going to step out I don't get the
guarantees I don't get the proofs I
don't get the you know what I mean I can
have reasons and such I'm not saying
like it's is completely irrational crazy
I'm not saying that but it's at the end
of the day it's it's not like a math
formula it just isn't there is this
invitation this profound invitation to
trust in other words maybe you're here
and you're like I am just I'm struggling
like I know it's Easter and I should be
full of faith and hooray Hallelujah you
know I should be but oh I'm struggling
to believe I am maybe it's it's not even
so much again intellectual maybe it's
just the season you're in it has has
just been hellish it's just been
difficult and you're like I just don't
even know if I if I can believe in God
anymore my my invitation would be that's
fine you know what just come
participate come participate so I don't
even know if I like really have the
faith I should in Christ that's fine
like just participate so I don't it's
Easter I'm not even sure if I believe in
the resurrection or at least not at the
level I should or something you know
what that's fine just
participate right because this is how we
come to know Resurrection Life it's
through an embodied
practice of um a life with God I
recently uh I finished a a little
five-part reality
TV that's right well Pastor Brett
watching that reality television I will
this will be the only reality TV series
I ever suggest anyone watch I think um
but although once I say the name you'll
be like okay this is fake so it's uh
it's a five-part it's really kind of a
reality television but it's also
documentary from 2006 a little old um
called the monastery you're like I knew
it I knew it this is fake reality
television all right but hang with me so
it just it highlighted this whole
process so powerfully for me so the I
knew kind of the I just from reading the
description I knew the general premise
going in so basically the reality
element of it is five men were invited
to or really kind of invited SL agreed
to participate in the life and rhythms
of this uh local Monastery uh there it's
called the monastery of Christ in the
desert in abue New Mexico it's a
primitive Benedictine Christian
Monastery and they committed to
basically be there and follow kind of
the way of life of the Christian monks
there for 40 days and 40 nights
now my assumption going is in was like
oh these will be like I guess I don't
know like Christian men who want to
maybe even feel called the priesthood or
something you know they want to start
going deeper in their life with God and
this is why I'm not a reality television
producer because that would have been
boring you know what I mean they're just
like how's it going they're like oh I
just love it you know it's like okay
well so no no so instead they chose
because they're good at this they chose
like five completely random I mean all
walks of life um socioeconomic
backgrounds ethnic I mean completely
different and different levels of like
Faith again I would have thought most of
probably chose people who believe in God
no nope and that's what made this
absolutely fascinating so you had like
here's some of the men they had um a
gentleman named Tom recovering alcoholic
uh grew up Catholic but had not been to
church in a long time uh and had been in
this kind of uh sober but then relapse
sober relapse but each time the relapse
was kind of more difficult and darker
and he's almost lost his life multiple
times and so he was kind of at a place
where he's like I don't know if God's
there but like I need something you know
so there's um there was Tom there was um
an
ex-convict and he through his teens and
20s um was kind of chasing the dollar so
he got into kind of gang life and was
selling drugs on the streets eventually
got caught went to prison for like a
decade uh came out and for the last
years had devoted his life to keep kids
off the streets which honestly was
beautiful and awesome but in the process
in the process of trying to kind of
atone for his sin so to speak he uh was
had basically turned into a workaholic
and so he's like complet he'd already
lost one marriage was utterly neglecting
his family as he's just working 14 16
hour days trying to keep these kids from
the same mistakes he made so he was
interesting he kind of came with kind of
his own you know for his own reasons
there was um a wounded veteran right
this is back in 2006 so Iraq war and a
young young guy um there was a former
Satanist turned Episcopalian so he was
the only Christian um
and and then there was um a first
responder who because of all the pain
he'd observed right the
suffering uh he had just kind of turned
into a really cold kind of cynical if
you are a first resp spner or you know
first spner you that's like a real
challenge to be in those lines of work
because you do you see the the kind of
um underbelly of society the you know
kind of the worst of the worst of
humanity or at the very least people on
their worst days you know and it and it
gets to you and it had gotten to him so
he probably going in he was the most
resistant like he was just like I think
this is stupid you know like he was so
all that to say to kind of set this up I
was just like this is going to be a
train wreck like you're D they don't
even know if they believe in God and
you're like come you know engage and so
this is what it was like up at 4:00 a.m.
morning prayers they went to mass or
church service eight times a day you
imagine you some of you good Catholics
like you know like that's a lot of
that's a lot of mass um there was I mean
what else oh they chanted through all
150 Psalms every single week just slowly
oh yeah I mean it was like totally this
is in craziness and honestly at first
the rhythm of the monastery it did it
chafed on them they just they didn't
totally get it I think the hardest thing
for them was the silence that was
another thing they took a vow where it
wasn't they had to be silent literally
all day every day but there was only
certain times that they could
speak so most of their day was just
spent
in and it like it was so challenging for
them and
yet slowly but surely you watch as week
one turns into week two week two into
week three that like slowly but surely
like they started to get it like you
could see where it went from this like
this is weird to like oh my gosh I think
something in me is starting to shift
there was Tom the the gentleman who was
alcoholic he had this moment where he
just sensed God kind of speaking to him
there was the um the ex-convict who they
took a day of silence and this pained
him because it turned out that while he
was in prison his brother had died also
on the streets this is part of what was
driving his
workaholism and so he finally in This
Day of Silence he realized like it was
finally space for him to grieve and all
the feelings started coming up at first
he was downright
panicky and then slowly but surely he
starts settling in he cries and he
realizes like oh my gosh it's it's not
so much I've been like running from God
like I've been running from myself and
this happens for each of them over and
over and over where they realized it
wasn't so much God's
absence it was it was their own kind of
struggles with their own heart and mind
in desires and and their own kind of
crazy you know and as they opened up
space for that it was
like their spiritual senses began to
come alive
and this is why it was just astounding
to me that it seemed like what they
needed was not more
information or argumentation the monks
never sat them down it's like now here's
the book of doctrines you know like do
you believe in the resurrection well
don't even think about saying these
prayers until you believe you know like
no it was what did they do they said
come
participate come participate enter in
enter into the process enter in and as
you do that something begins to open up
that's what happened for those men and
this is why I would say that the
greatest danger to faith in God in
Christ Resurrection Life it's it's not
atheism it's not skepticism or or
rational
argumentation no it's rather a
noisy busy cluttered ill
culture that drowns our spiritual senses
before they've ever even had a chance to
awake before they've ever had a chance
to awake and and so like church that's
the invitation in this
message is is not so much like believe
you know just make yourself as though
you could White Knuckle that I don't
even know what that would mean how do
you make yourself like I'm just going to
believe like you can't no I'm going to
say come
participate come participate come begin
to give yourself over to rhythms of
Prayer in silence in
scripture come participate in community
where you can be honest in
real come
engage the practices like this is how we
come to become settled in Resurrection
Life no no not having to White Knuckle
it anymore you know and what happens
when we do that suddenly 1 Corinthians
15:
42-4 like these are not just verses that
we have to force ourselves to believe
you're like no you just become
settled that something here is true that
I am more than
just this that you are more than just
what you see but you you are spirit and
Resurrection Life and hope is your
future and I believe this is a message
like our culture needs because there's
so much
pessimism and and there's such a sense
of kind of futility like what is the
point of all this and we've got to know
that our end our our tellos our our end
point is Resurrection Life you you are a
profoundly spiritual being
at your
core and and what we need is space for
that spiritual sense to again come
alive so this year let's commit not just
to give mental Ascent to doctrines the
doctrine of God the doctrine of Christ
the doctrine of the Resurrection like
let's commit to the spiritual path let's
be people who wake up to Christ in the
spirit amen amen would you go ahead and
bow your heads close your eyes and I
want to speak this prayer over
us Lord
Jesus this
Easter I pray that the Waters of Faith
might begin to flow within thirsty
hearts that the Winds of Hope might blow
in dry in arid souls and that a radiant
love might shine again upon spiritual
senses long cold and dormant oh holy
spirit enliven us resurrected Christ
awaken us that your Resurrection Life
might find us in the name of the father
and the son and the holy spirit
amen so if you attend the table uh
regularly you know we participate in
communion and tonight we're going to do
this a little bit differently it'll be a
little more of a an Easter Twist on a a
very um old kind of ritual and Sacrament
so uh the way we've been in the season
of lint right 40 days of preparation
kind of leading up to Good Friday a few
days ago and now um Easter and if you're
there for Ash Wednesday There's this
ritual you've ever seen people with
ashes on their forehead you know and in
in some traditions they'll say um from
dust you came to dust you return so on
this Easter Day what we want to invite
you to receive is um some lavender oil
upon your forehead and I'll just make a
circle it'll just be a sign of the empty
tomb and instead of from dust you came
to dust you return it will be from dust
you came but to Resurrection Life you
return because this is this is your
future this is your your call and so so
the way that we'll do this um is we'll
just kind of go row by row we'll start
in the front and we'll just form a line
right here and you can come forward um
once I make the sign of the empty tomb
you can just kind of Branch off in in
your the direction wherever you're
seated um you can go back to that that
space um you should also know this is an
open time so if you're here tonight and
something resonates with you you you
want to receive this for yourself then
you are welcome to do that regardless of
exact belief um or denominational
affiliation or anything and uh at the
same time if you're here and you you
know would rather not participate that's
okay too there's no you no one's going
to no one's going to give you the stink
eye like get up there you know that's
you're you're good you're good so uh
with that in mind uh as a b place I I
want to just invite you forward uh to
receive this and then we'll have a
closing song after that so come
[Music]
forward
from dust you
[Music]
came
for
[Music]
oh my words fall
short I got nothing new
how could I
express oh my
gratitude I could sing these
songs as I often
do but every song must
end and you never
[Music]
so I throw up my hands praise you again
and
again cuz all that I have
[Music]
ISU
Hallelujah I know it's not
much nothing else fit for
[Music]
except for a heart singing
hu
[Music]
hallelu I've got one
response I've got just one
move
with my arms stretched
wide I will worship
you
oh so I throw up my hands and praise you
again and
again cuz all that I have is
[Music]
aelu
halel
I know it's not much have nothing else
fit
foring except for a heart
[Music]
singing
Hallelujah
[Music]
so come on my soul oh don't you get shy
on me lift up your s cuz you've got a
lion inside of those Longs get up and
praise the
Lord would you guys stand with us if you
would like oh come on my soul oh don't
you get shy of he lift up your song cuz
you've got a lion inside of those Lo get
up and praise the
Lord oh come on my soul don't you get
shy on me and lift up your song CU
you've got a li inside of
those up and praised
[Music]
world
so I throw up my
hands praise you again and
[Music]
again cuz all that I have is a
heartu
[Music]
hallelu I know it's not much but I've
have nothing else for
King except for heart singing
allelu
[Music]
halelu
Hallelujah well thank you so much for
joining us this evening um if you guys
are new we would love for you to fill
out a card on the little table over here
to the side uh on your way out or you
can just uh scan the QR
code um and um it's an online visitors
card and that will allow us to be able
to follow up answer any questions that
you may have and say thank you for
visiting with us
today um if you're in need of a prayer
or a hug or just uh any kind of General
support you can find me after the
service my name is johnine and I'll be
happy to uh meet with you okay don't
forget there is an egg hunt for the
kiddos parents uh meet the at the kids
checkin and there's a potluck meal in
the Family Life Center happening
immediately after the service so we'd
love for you to stay and
participate um in that all right
now I'd like to
uh send you into this Easter with this
blessing if you can hold out your hands
in a posture to receive or you can just
let your open up your heart to receive
these
words you are a child of
God you are a child of
God and this is true on your very best
day and it's true on your worst day so
as you go into your week ahead with it's
yet to be determined highs and lows and
everything in
between go filled with the assurance
that you are loved that you are worthy
and that you are accepted just just as
you are and go filled with God's Holy
Spirit and the desire to extend these
same Gifts of Grace and unconditional
love to everyone that you come in
contact with and the Lord bless you and
our food as we celebrate the
resurrection life
amen oh come on my soul oh don't you get
shy on me lift up your song cuz you got
a lion inside of
those get up and praise the
Lord oh come on my soul oh don't you get
shy on me lift up your s cuz you've got
a lion inside of
get up and praise the
Lord come on my soul oh don't you get
shy on me lift up your song you got a
lion inside of those L get up and praise
the
Lord
[Music]
oh